[Music]
hello and welcome to i'd like to know
this is our bible question and answer
program i am ca murray and i'm in the
presence of our and he has so many
titles sometimes we call you speaker
director sometimes we call you president
we can add founder to that uh any number
of titles that are appropriate this is
pastor stephen bohr
and
we have a good time together on this
program as you will know don't see when
i came to work at secrets and sale i
found out that pastor bohr
in addition to being a student of the
world has a great sense of humor and is
a great person to be around and uh we
have a lot of fun on this program
because we get to answer your questions
we like studying the word of god and we
like being given assignments to study
the word of god so we make you this
promise as we always do that the answers
that we give will come from the word of
god it will not be his thoughts will not
be my thoughts they will be the thoughts
of god as we understand them you send in
a question if an answer can be found in
the word of god we will find it and give
it to you from the word of god that is
the promise we make to you
we have a
quite a stack of questions but we can
always take more so if you'd like to
send in a question you'd like to have a
question answered be it be be it a
lighter question or a very serious
question we will give you the answer if
we can find it
you want to write to tv
at some tv.org that is tv
at some tv.org
and we will do our best to get the
answers to you we're going to get right
into the program uh we'll have a word of
prayer and uh then we'll start and
launch out we've got a couple good
questions today pastor i think i'll pray
and uh okay then we'll shoot the first
question at your great kind self
father god we thank you we praise you
for the wonderful
word that you've given to your people a
word that gives us edification that
gives us information and that prepares
us for the day when christ shall come
again and for citizenship in heaven
bless now this sitting as we go into
your word be the teacher be the
instructor and give us your truth and we
thank you in advance for what you have
promised to do in the per con answer to
the prayer of faith in jesus name amen
amen
all right pastor this question comes
from richard
and
he's got really two parts here
and he thanks uh uh us for a very
informative show he wants to know
will humans lose the ability to
procreate when they receive their
immortal bodies
okay the bible is very clear on that
point
in the gospel of luke
in a conversation that jesus had with
the sadducees
by the way the sadducees did not believe
in the resurrection of the dead yes
in luke chapter 20
and verses 34 and 35
we have the answer of jesus
so i think it's pretty authoritative to
have the words of jesus indeed to answer
this question
it says there jesus answered and said to
them
that is to the sadducees
the sons of this age
in other words
this sinful period of human history the
sons of this age
marry
and are given in marriage
but
those who are counted worthy to attain
that age in other words the age to come
when we receive our immortal bodies
so once again but those who are counted
worthy to attain that age
and the resurrection from the dead
neither mary
nor are given in marriage
nor can they die anymore for they are
equal to the angels and our sons of god
being sons of the resurrection
so i think that these verses make it
very clear
that there will be no more marriages
when we receive our immortal bodies and
of course uh there's not going to be any
procreation either if there's no
marriage a couple things come to mind
pastor um one
uh
the institution of marriage was given
for
a number of reasons one that man would
not be alone but also in response to the
command be fruitful multiply
there is no such command in heaven uh so
you don't we don't have that i don't
want to say burden but we don't have
that that commandment given to us uh in
heaven
i have not seen earth not heard
so
so much of what we think about heaven is
speculative you know because we have not
been there um
we we haven't
really gotten a grasp on what heaven is
like we know that
we're a little more comfortable talking
about what won't be in heaven no more
death no more sin no more sorrow we can
give you a long list of things that
won't be there but we don't know
everything that will be there
we're going to grow we're going to learn
we're going to there's so many things
we're going to do suffice it to say god
loves us with an everlasting love
no good thing will he withhold from us
so if
there is not
the procreative
aspect of heaven there's going to be
something more you know it's it's not
heaven is not going to be worse than
earth it's not going to be more sad than
earth it's going to be better so
whatever god has got planned for us it's
going to be better because god has
promised so so we have to sort of rely
on that because there's no way for us
our minds to really encompass all that
heaven is about because we have not had
the experience
uh you know ellen white expands upon
what we just read from the gospel of
luke
and i'd like to concur with what you
said uh you know some people say well
you know if there's no marriage in
heaven i don't want to go there because
i love my wife and i want to be with my
wife well you know we don't really know
whether husbands and wives are going to
live together you know even though
there's no new marriages and exactly
what the arrangement is but we do know
that there's not going to be any more
marriages
in the earth made new
in the book medical ministry page 99 and
100 ellen white was explicit when she
wrote these words
there are men today
who express their belief that there will
be marriages and births
in the new earth but those who believe
the scriptures cannot accept such
doctrines
the doctrine that children will be born
in the new earth
is not a part of the sure word of
prophecy
the words of christ are too plain to be
misunderstood
they should forever settle the question
of marriages and births in the new earth
neither those who shall be raised from
the dead
nor those who shall be translated
without seeing death
will marry or be given in marriage
they will be as the angels of god
members of the royal family
so i think that's pretty explicit that
in the new earth there will be no
marriage and no births either yes and
and this is addressed
christ's statement
um
follows a a questioning by the sadducees
about a guy marries one and she dies and
he marries another and you know so
they're trying to trap him a little bit
uh so it was in response to a question
about marriage that this whole statement
came so we can pretty much uh understand
what uh christ had to say and that is
that uh sort of puts the cap on what
that right what the bible says yeah okay
now you threw this curveball at me so
i'm going to throw you a knuckleball
in the next question
this is a rather long one
but i'm going to take the time to read
it because it has some good thoughts in
it
first of all
the person who sent this who is silas
wrote may god almighty continue blessing
your ministry i have been greatly
blessed by the many sermons you make
available on youtube only god will
reward you
reward you for your tireless work then
here comes the question my question or
perhaps observation
is on the mark of the beast
i understand that in the last days
perhaps even in our lifetime
given the fast pace at which global
events are unfolding
there will be a law compelling the
observance of sunday worship
and that those who will choose to
observe that law that is the sunday law
will have the mark of the beast
i have heard many pastors including
yourself that is me
say that the mark of the beast has not
yet come
this in my view gives the impression
that for now it is okay to worship on
sunday
doesn't this somewhat water down the
first angel's message to fear god and
worship the creator
in my testifying to non-adventists
i urge them to make the decision now
because they don't know when they may
die
and therefore should not wait until the
law comes
if after knowing the truth and refusing
to stop sunday worship they die
they will have died with the mark of the
beast
is it wrong to testify thus
i would appreciate well this person says
i would appreciate if you let me know in
advance when this question is going to
be answered so
how do we answer this uh rather lengthy
question
you know something comes to my mind you
said you threw me a knuckleball a
knuckleball is rather hard to hit
because a curveball you can follow the
ark a knuckleball you don't know where
it's coming from
um here's something that popped up in in
my mind
uh and i'm going to james chapter 2
verse 10.
sort of coming from a a left uh
left-handed approach here
james says and i'll give the dice we'll
just read it
uh james 2 10 he says for whoever shall
keep the whole law and yet stumble in
one point is guilty of all for he who
said do not commit adultery also said do
not murder now if you do not commit
adultery but you murder you have become
a transgressor of the law all right we
stopped there
we understand that the market obese will
not
come into play until
sunday observance is
forcibly um
forced to be forcibly kept it's going to
be
kept by force
but
here's how my mind works on this if a
person
knows the commandments
and breaks the commandments
and dies as a commandment breaker
he he is a a a lost person if he dies
knowing the commandments and rejecting
long before the mark of the beast comes
commandment number four says the sabbath
day is the seventh day and if you are
aware of that and refuse to keep it then
you are a commandment breaker and should
you die you die as a commandment breaker
so you're you're guilty james says if if
you keep this and you keep that and you
keep seven and you keep the the eight
and you keep the nine to keep the ten
and break the fourth you are a
commandment breaker you've broken the
chain
so you die as a commandment breaker so
the call is today if you hear his voice
harden out your heart today so that
you're not a commandment breaker long
before the mark of the beast that's just
another
piece of the puzzle but you want to be
found a commandment keeper here and now
today and we should make that choice
here and now today
and you know the person who dies
before the mark of the beast is enforced
i would not say that they have the mark
of the beast
but like you say
because they had clearly revealed light
and they decided to go against it
then if they die
while they're still rejecting the clear
light precisely then
they're going to be lost but they don't
have the mark of the beast correct
because the mark of the beast comes when
the sunday law
is enforced uh by the united states and
then it becomes a global
sunday decree precisely so a person when
a person dies they don't necessarily
have the mark of the beast
but they're still lost because they
rejected
the light that god gave chris any of the
ten commandments sure can be grounds for
i don't say grounds fear expulsion
because it sounds a little too
pedagogical but we are called if you
love me john 17 17 christ says keep my
commandments we know we have an
obligation as christians to keep the
commandments of god and if you are a
command breaker you cannot be you cannot
be one with god right yeah
yeah so um the key is a verse that you
mentioned if you hear his voice today
do not harden your heart harden your
heart because you know a person a person
might hear the message on the sabbath
and reject it for a period of time
and then accept it
well that person's door of probation did
not close when they first heard the
sabbath message and rejected it god
continues speaking to them
and trying to encourage them
to be obedient to his law yes
as you well know why do we preach so
hard why do we work up uh so much energy
and exit exigency preaching so that
those who maybe didn't hear it the first
time will be convicted when they hear it
the second time right uh and god does
not give up on them uh he keeps wooing
and will do so until the door of
probation closes so there's always an
opportunity once you hear that you will
respond
so when this person says is it wrong for
him to say
that if a person who is studying now
if they reject the sabbath they will
receive the mark of the beast probably
it would be better for in the bible
study to say if you reject the sabbath
you're on very dangerous grounds and if
you should die rejecting the sabbath
you're going to be lost whether you have
the mark of the beast or not or not
i want to read this statement by ellen
white where she she's explicit in
answering this question the book
evangelism 234 and 235 she wrote
no one has yet received the mark of the
beast
the testing time has not yet come
there are true christians in every
church
not accepting the roman catholic
communion
here's the key point none are condemned
until they have had the light
and have seen the obligation of the
fourth commandment
but
when the decree shall go forth
enforcing the counterfeit sabbath and
the loud cry of the third angel shall
warn men against the worship of the
beast in his image
the line will be clearly drawn between
the false and the true
then those who still continue
in transgression will receive the mark
of the beast
so very very clear praise the lord you
know i'm looking at silas
he is a notary public and he's a partner
in a fairly impressive form uh form so
maybe he has a a platform from which to
to to tout this uh he does say correctly
you never know when you're going to die
well that rationale ought to be applied
to all of the commandments in fact to
everything that god tells us to do you
don't know if you're going to wake up
tomorrow so today again if you hear his
voice don't harden your hearts don't
turn away uh follow him and accept him
and let him lead so it's a great
question yeah as it says in the book of
hebrews says appointed man to die once
and after the judgment so in other words
uh if a person accepts christ and dies
their case is closed yes if a person
dies and rejected christ and his message
that person's case is closed as well
there's not going to be a second
probability it's not going to be a
second so that's the reason why a
decision needs to be made today to keep
the sabbath and not wait until the the
issue becomes the mark of the beast
okay now here's another question which
is very interesting
it uh comes i'm assuming that from an
individual called alex
and actually comes from germany
this is the question
and probably if you can start searching
for ephesians chapter 2 and verse 15. ca
and i'll have you read that uh meanwhile
i'll read the question
i greet you dear brothers by the way
thank you for watching from germany we
appreciate it
i have the following question
how do you explain ephesians 2 15
god bless you
i will read ephesians 2 15 i'm reading
from the new king james having abolished
in his flesh the enmity that is the law
of commandments contained in ordinances
so as to create in himself
one new man from the two thus making
peace
you know you almost want to just
continue and finish the sentence finish
the thought by including 16 also
and that he might reconcile them both to
god in one body through the cross
thereby putting to death the enmity
um
one of the things that we know and
i've got a bunch of texts that i i wrote
down second corinthians 5 17 colossians
1 22 hebrews 10 19 through 22
is that
one of the things that the death on the
cross did
and we're talking about christ dying in
the flesh
was it it
it
satisfied if i can use that term the
enmity or the antagonism between the law
and the grace of god and us being like
christ jesus he gave us the opportunity
through his death
to be partakers of the divine nature
thereby
creating not an improvement on but a new
man a new man who was one with christ so
that the antagonism the enmity that that
was there
during the life of the old man is no
longer there because the a new man has
been created who is at peace with god
and who is walking with god and all of
these texts that i enumerated
tend to give you a piece of that puzzle
and and create that picture for you
yeah another uh uh perhaps dimension of
this is
that the context is indicating that the
enmity here is between jew and gentile
because uh it says in verse 11 therefore
remember that you were once gentiles in
the flesh yes who are called
uncircumcision
by what is called the circumcision made
in the flesh by hands
that at that time you were this is
speaking of the gentiles that at that
time you were without christ
being aliens from the commonwealth of
israel and strangers from the covenant
of promise having no hope and without
hope
having no hope and without god in the
world
but now in christ jesus you have
you who were once afar off have been
brought near by the blood of christ
i think that when the apostle
paul mentions here in verse 15 that god
abolished in his uh jesus abolished in
his flesh the enmity
that is the law
of commandments contained in ordinances
i think it's referring to the ceremonial
law yes it is the ceremonial law was
an obstacle between jew and gentile
and we can see that
by for example
the book of acts
let's go to acts chapter 10 and verse 28
you know the the ceremonial law in
itself
was not the creator of enmity but the
jews shut down the door for the gentiles
to come in yes and therefore there was
the enmity
but in acts chapter 10 verse 28 this is
experience of
peter and the sheep coming down with all
the unclean animals
notice the perspective that
peter had of the gentiles before god
enlightened him yes
then he said to them you know how
unlawful it is for a jewish man to keep
company with or go to
one of another nation but god has shown
me that i should not call any man common
or unclean
so at this point
there's a there's a rift between jew and
gentile
but god by showing peter the sheet three
times with the unclean animals god told
him don't you consider the gentiles
unclean
so this ceremonial prescription here
that that is mentioned in verse 28 that
it's unlawful for a jewish man to keep
company with a gentile
is taken away by the cross of christ
because jesus died for jew and for
gentile
[Music]
another
interesting
point that we can find here is uh the
jerusalem council
uh remember that there was a big debate
at the jerusalem council yes how much
should they be how much jewishness
should they
take on to because
so there was this divisive point on
circumcision
it's not that circumcision circumcision
should have caused the rift
but the the jews had caused the rift for
making it because they made this ceremo
ceremony an obstacle for the gentiles to
benefit fully and completely from the
blessings of god
you know what i see here also is is
affirm the fact that uh in christ
and i'll use some common language being
a jew doesn't get you any points
you know
and the ritual the ritualism of judaism
doesn't get you any points it's your
love of christ
and accepting the surrender that um
christ has made for you so
jew gentiles start at the same place you
know start at jesus and you build up
from there you don't get a head start
because you're jewish
because right christ is doing a brand
new thing and you've got to walk into it
as a jew just as you walk into it as a
gentile right
and you know the succeeding context
uh in chapter 2 of ephesians 19 to 22.
you have the
the apostle paul's conclusion to this
whole matter
he says now therefore
you are no longer strangers and
foreigners he says to the gentiles
but fellow citizens with the saints and
members of the household of god
having been built on the foundation of
the apostles and prophets
jesus christ himself being the chief
cornerstone yes in whom the whole
building being fitted together grows
into a holy temple in the lord in whom
you also are being built together for a
dwelling place of god in the spirit so i
think the the main gist of the passage
is
that the ceremonial law
had been made an obstacle by the jewish
nation for the gentiles to enjoy the
benefits of the covenant and the apostle
paul is saying listen the cross of
christ
uh verse 13 says but now in christ jesus
you who are once far off have been
brought near by the blood of christ and
then it says that in the cross of christ
the enmity has been done away because
all of the ceremonial system was
fulfilled it was fulfilled it was
fulfilled yeah and i think it was
important that these kinds of statements
be made because something was being
erected as a barricade or a barrier that
should not be uh it was not intended to
be uh the jews were making it so uh thus
the jerusalem council you know we have a
couple things we need to stay abstain
from flesh some other kind of things but
all of this other stuff you're putting
on is not is not of the lord and you
don't need to come through jesus through
judaism to get to jesus you go straight
to jesus as a christian you know there's
an interesting parallel
verse to this one colossians chapter 2
and verse 16 where it says let no man
judge you
in meat or drink
or holy day or festival or sabbath day
some people take that to abolish the
sabbath because nobody can judge me
whether i keep the sabbath or not
but but really
it goes on to say that these things were
shadows of things to come but the bodies
of christ in other words the ceremonial
law was taken out of the way yes and of
course those sabbaths are the ceremonial
sabbaths
the new moons are the new moons from the
ceremonial system the festivals are the
jewish festivals that pointed forward to
the messiah
in other words all of these things were
taken out of the way yes and therefore
they should not be imposed on the
gentiles creating enmity that way yes
yes yes um i picked it up at verse 22
but i'm glad you kind of went back a
couple verses because uh it does it does
clear it up that things were being asked
of the gentile world which are not
necessary but this is not talking about
the ten commandments these are those
things which were put in the side of the
ark which were the additional uh
regulations uh that certainly pointed to
jesus but which jesus fulfilled and
which were no longer necessary for the
new testament yeah you know the ten
commandments are not at enmity with us
we're at enmity with the ten
commandments amen
so true so you know that the law of god
is eternal it's for our good amen the
law is holy just and good the apostle
paul said so the problem is not with the
ten commandments the problem is with sin
that abides in our hearts as the apostle
paul says in our flesh and therefore we
are at enmity with the law yes not the
law
you know it's interesting and and i'll
say this because i've run into it so
many times
most people don't have any problem with
nine of the commandments we know
it's always been wrong to commit
adultery to to covet to steal to lie
we don't have any problem with those but
the ten commandments is a chain of ten
links and of course james says if you
break one you're you're guilty of
breaking the chain the only place we
want to sort of pop that chain apart is
that commandment number four yeah and
that's the longest of of them all and
the one that says remember
yeah
and uh and it's the seal yes because it
identifies
the giver of the law it identifies his
territory and it identifies also his
function in other words why he is an
authority that can also proclaim his law
very true if you pulled out commandment
number four you wouldn't really have a
very clear idea of who wrote the ten
commandments right because god signs his
name there and you need that to identify
the author yeah yeah well i hope that
this answer has been satisfactory you
know time has flown by as usual uh when
we're having a good time studying the
word of god uh the clock becomes our
greatest enmity
being that we're on that central theme
but anyway we want to i thank you once
again for tuning in to the program i'd
like to know you'll see on the screen
where you can send your questions tv at
some tv.org
we'd love to receive your questions you
know we'll do the research and if
there's an answer in the bible we will
do everything possible to find it may
god bless you and once again thank you
for tuning in to our program i'd like to
know
[Music]
you